not a cloud in sight and tristan
mckenzie
getting the opportunity of a lifetime
here tonight something he's waited a
long time for mckenzie's wide and his
first pitch in the big leagues here's a
fastball strike that is nolan
jones is that right the one of the top
prospects for the indians he wanted to
come in to see his buddy get his first
start so the best way he could do it is
come over here
at the ballpark huh well he's over at
the other side and i know tristan has
made his way over here a few times to
watch games as well but they've got to
stay away and there's only certain ways
that they can come in the park in
certain times the o2
swing and a miss got him of the slider
and miguel cabrera gets a first-hand
look at what the indians hope is another
future star starting pitcher
how about that first inning in your
major league debut tristan mckenzie
three up three down
tristan mckenzie you see
what the scouts have talked about the
live arm
it's not just the what the radar gun
tells you
it just jumps on that hitter you can
tell if it's on you in a hurry
[Applause]
[Applause]
97 miles an hour that was nasty first
time through the order mckenzie strikes
out four
walks one tristan mckenzie has faced the
minimum through the first three innings
here's willy castro
castro puts a charge into one
sia tigers draw first blood in cleveland
whoa that was a bomb
way back sat on a changeup kid made a
mistake it was up out over the plate and
willy castro he puts a charge second
homer of the season for willie castro
and the fourth homer of the series for
the tigers
blew it right by him for the second time
tonight he strikes out miguel cabrera
five k's for mckenzie
now jacoby jones he drew a walk the only
walk issued by mckenzie oh man went
right to work on him
with a fastball that's his sixth
strikeout of the night
kristen stewart
and he takes a fastball strike three
called
seven for tristan mckenzie two down for
austin romine and the one-two
swung on and missed foul tipped into the
mitt of roberto perez eight strikeouts
for mckenzie the top of the sixth inning
is tristan mckenzie's making his major
league debut some have asked and some
may see the ssa on the side of his hat
he had a female cousin that passed away
suddenly back in high school so he's
been doing that since high school for a
cousin that passed away when he was
younger and he always wanted to do it
here on the major league level
swung out and missed he ate him up again
this is something else that's four
straight strikeouts he's had about
110212 pounds he's thrown strikes he's
he's been ahead of almost all hitters
good night i mean not even fair
breakouts in the major league debut and
the most strikeouts in a major league
debut for the cleveland indians he's in
the number two spot right now more than
the big man herbie score
tian is number one domingo santana
coming to the plate with the bases
loaded
there's a line drive up the middle and
into left center field ramirez ties the
game lindor gives the indians the lead
here comes luplow here's the throw to
the plate he is hey
it's a three-run double with two outs
here in the six for domingo santana and
the indians have come back to take the
lead they finally get the big hit to
break one open here tonight
and there's a base hit in the left field
domingo's coming around
mancelino will send him home here's the
throw it's cut off or they tried to cut
her off and missed and so not only do
you get a run but roberto gets in the
scoring position as well
and it's a four run six for the tribe
carlos santana
how much it add on again
left field stewart backing up he
has no chance to throw out the runner
cesar hernandez
and the indians
increase their lead 5-1
back to the top of the order
line drive base hit left field greg
allen's coming around third they'll wave
him stuart once again throws this time
it is cut off
it's 6-1 cleveland and hernandez
will be tagged out to end the inning
miguel cabrero
[Applause]
this should do it jose ramirez with the
throw it's on the money and the indians
bounce back and beat the tigers by a
final score of 6-1 and
tristan mckenzie gets the win in his
major league debut